welcome to the twilight zone though not
a Twilight Zone
the oceanic Twilight Zone one of the
most mysterious ecosystems on earth 200
to 500 feet under the surface it gets
dark during the day like scary dark
usually coral needs sunlight to survive
yet here a reef thrives researchers at
the California Academy of Sciences in
San Francisco are finding that these
deep brief corals get their energy in a
clever way in contrast to shallow water
reefs which are largely driven by
sunlight Twilight Zone reefs exist kind
of as the sunlight starts to disappear
as it's darker there there's less
photosynthetic corals and they're more
corals that rely upon filter feeding or
catching and eating plankton bacterias
from detritus and debris that floats
down from shallower waters up until now
the reefs of The Twilight Zone have been
too deep from normal scuba diving and
too shallow to justify the expense of
exploring with a submersible but thanks
for some fancy new diving tech the
Academy of Sciences is finally bringing
the deeper to the public with a first of
its kind exhibit one of the most
fascinating animals we got for this new
exhibit our benthic pinafores they have
very long tentacles that looked like
long fishing lines and that they
captured plankton with them bringing the
creatures up from the deep was a
tremendous challenge particularly with
fish whose air-filled swim bladders can
get kind of well bloody that swim
bladder represents a problem to us
because when we reduce the ambient
pressure for a fish the swim bladder
expands and it crushes all the other
organs inside the fish so the Academy
invented its own mini decompression
chamber in the deep divers collect fish
and seal them inside at that point that
becomes the world's deepest aquarium we
hand it off to surface support team and
then they control the decompression of
those fish over a period of up to about
48 hours slowly acclimating them to the
surface pressure that they will be
living in when they
to our aquarium diving to such depths
also presents huge problems for the
divers themselves typical scuba gear can
get you only around an hour of dive time
breathing oxygen and nitrogen but at
these depths divers breathe not nitrogen
but helium a very expensive gas so the
academy's divers use what's known as a
rebreather which cycles the helium
instead of releasing it all into the
water so with the rebreather everything
goes back into the system there's a
canister in our back that filters the
carbon dioxide out and then we keep
reading the same helium over and over
again
and add oxygen as we need it we can stay
underwater with a rebreather for five
six seven hours that's key to being able
to reach the deep reefs since the divers
have to spend so much time decompressing
on their way back up and the urgency to
explore and understand the twilight zone
is real shallow coral reefs are
suffering terribly from both warming
seas and pollution whether the deep
reefs of The Twilight Zone can avoid the
same fate isn't yet clear but just maybe
this strange place can serve as a refuge
as the oceans transform after all
weirder things have happened in the
twilight zone